okay several things do have to be said
before we can bring this event to a
close first thanks I would like to thank
once again all of the scheduled speakers
for showing uncharacteristic discipline
in maintaining control over the time
element that was that was critical I'd
like to thank ray goldberg personally
and directly for as The Godfather of the
study of many of these things at Harvard
you're the knowledge that you would be
here was an inspiration to me and to
many of the rest of us so I want to
thank you for taking the time to to be
here during the entire session this
afternoon I'd like to thank the members
of our steering committee those of you
who are here I won't embarrass you by
forcing you to stand up at please at
least raise your hands at least briefly
thank you thank you thank you very much
the names are right here we had of
course the assistance from some highly
capable conference organizers from the
Kennedy School from the Weatherhead
center and and elsewhere could you
please raise your hands as well and will
thank you and i would like to embarrass
just newman and ask her to stand up very
quickly jess is a bill made the trains
run on time but I've got to say jess is
the one who put the train on the tracks
and as our as our RSVP list kept growing
on just somehow stayed ahead of the
problem and helped us make all the
adjustments and then a very personal
thanks again to Steve Bloomfield from
the Weatherhead center I can't stress
enough how important in to spend for for
Steve to put institutional support
behind cross school and
cross-disciplinary work on food and
agriculture at Harvard University over
the last four or five or more years so
Steve thank you and the Weatherhead
center very very much thanks thanks all
also to our generous co-sponsors as well
as our sponsors listed on your handout
and and finally I'd like to to thank the
the lead co-organizer of the conference
bill clark at the Harvard Kennedy School
bill bill not only kept us on schedule
and actually ahead of schedule bill was
essential to to envisioning this event
Bill thinks big he didn't want to do
this in a small way he wanted to do it
in a big way that meant an ambitious
effort to recruit Harvard faculty to
come and willingness then to keep
expanding the venue as necessary to
satisfy the growing audience so bill
this has been a wonderful a tribute to
your skills into your vision and to your
hopes for what the university can be
focusing on in the years going ahead
thanks now also to our our audience our
audience we hope we hope for you here
including students as well as faculty
that this isn't the end of something
that this is the beginning of an ongoing
conversation here at the university over
the issues that are important to to all
of us we invite you to return
irregularly to our conference website
which will remain active you will see
there eventually recordings of the
presentations including those that you
might have missed materials will be
posted to support little seven minute
presentations with some actual published
materials if you want to go into more
detail the the Twitter responses will
eventually be seen there and keep those
responses coming in that remain an
active part of the conference and as
bill said at the outset we're planning
also to provide a comments reactions
link so that those of you who want to
make more extended contributions in way
of suggesting things we can do next or
commenting on this session you can you
can go ahead and do that and we remind
you also to do take note of the the
various related food
events that will be scheduled later this
spring I think they're listed in your
handout they've been listed on some of
the slides on the screen in front of you
not just at Harvard but at other
universities in the area we have two
sister university in the air at Tufts at
MIT that have their own full schedule of
activities in this area and we hope that
this can evolve into a a Boston wide
collaboration among universities not
just across schools within universities
so now to conclude we'd like to we'd
like to correct one serious omission
we've spent the entire afternoon talking
about food but we haven't served you any
food and so those of you who want to
continue the conversation over food and
drink we invite you now to to go to a
reception that is beginning immediately
on the third floor of this building
either walk up the stairs or take the
elevator it's at the Harvard Center for
the environment and I'll hope to see you
there and thank you very much